President Donald Trump's son in law and senior
adviser Jared Kushner bragged in April as the
country was reopening under Donald Trump's
direction about how Donald Trump took control
back from the doctors. Understand what this means.
Here is Jared Kushner bragging to Bob Woodward,
apparently having ill advised conversations
with Bob Woodward runs in the Trump family.
Here is Jared Kushner bragging about this.
The last thing was kind of doing the guidelines,
which was interesting. And that, in my mind was
almost like it was almost like Trump getting the
country back from the doctor straight in the sense
that what he now did was, you know, he's going
to only the open up. There were three phases.
There's the panic phase, the pain phase and then
the comeback phase. That doesn't mean there's not
still a lot of pain and there won't be pain for a
while. But that basically was we've now put out
rules to get back to work. Trump's now back in
charge. It's not the doctors they've got us.
We have to negotiate a settlement,
taking the country back from the doctors during
a global pandemic. We need the doctors. Imagine
saying we've got to take the airplanes back
from the pilots. All of these checklists and
fuel calculations and talking about what
do we do if we have to do an emergency?
We got to take control back from these pilots,
will cut down the turnaround time by 30 minutes
each way, and we'll be able to fly an additional
flight every single day. That's essentially what
they're saying here. Let's take the clearing of
toilet backups back from the plumbers, my friends.
It's time to get these overconfident idiot
plumbers out of here. That's a phrase Jared
Kushner will use in this next clip. Remember when
they said, what was it? We need a businessman
running the country like a business? Well,
he saw himself as negotiating with doctors
to get more deaths in exchange for
some businesses opening. Take a listen.
The most dangerous people around the president
are overconfident idiots. Right. Because that has
a way sometimes of getting past his defense
mechanism. Because if you're overconfident,
then sometimes, you know, on a topic where
he doesn't have other people around to kind
of validate it, then he can sometimes say,
OK, let's go with that. So that's kind of I
think if you look at the evolution of time, we've
gotten rid of a lot of the overconfident idiots.
And now he's got a lot more thoughtful people
who kind of know their place and know what to do.
The most dangerous people around Trump
are overconfident idiots like Jared,
not like the doctors. Instead, they want
people who know their place, like, for example,
doctors who will let Trump do whatever he wants.
People like Scott Atlas, who is actually the
epitome of an overconfident idiot, a neuro
radiologist who was brought in to deal with
an infectious disease. But Scott Atlas knows his
place. Very revealing comments from Jared Kushner.
And then this next one is really just stunning.
It's Kushner confirming exactly what I've been
saying for years about both Donald Trump and his
followers. It's not about issues. It's not about
policy. It's about attitude. It's about pissing
people off. And Kushner says it. Listen to this.
And so, you know, you look at like the
Republican Party platform. It's a document
meant like piss people off, basically,
because it's done by activists. Yeah. So
you have a disproportionality between
what issues people are vocal on and.
And what the people, the voters really care about
and what Trump's been able to do, as I say, he's
basically get a hostile takeover of the Republican
Party. And I don't think it's even as much about
the issue as I think it's about the attitude.
Just Jared Kushner completely laying bare
every one of our worst suspicions about these
people. And it's been obvious for a long time
that this had happened. But to hear
them say it's so overtly is chilling.
Trump claims to be a great businessman,
Jared Kushner, a great businessman. And yet
they don't realize that the way to get the economy
back is not to reopen prematurely. It was always
to deal with the pandemic that would naturally fix
the economy. They've never understood it. And so
it just goes on and on. And now Trump is endlessly
repeating, oh, Biden wants to lock everything down
fout. She wants to lock everything down, everyone.
But Trump wants to take away your freedoms.
But the goal isn't to lock down and restrict
freedoms. It's let's unite against a common
enemy and deal with the pandemic to save both
American lives and to save the economy in the
long term. The economy would naturally recover
with the pandemic under control. And instead,
this administration has said, let's get the
doctors out of here. Let's force openings,
because the focus was, I guess, short term gains,
even though I believe it has completely backfired.
Let's see if the election results bear that
out. And, you know, at the tail end of this,
if you open too early, you're almost guaranteeing
another shutdown. And even if it's not an official
shutdown, it's people who are going to stay home
here in Massachusetts as cases have gone from
150 a day to three hundred, six hundred, twelve
hundred. And now even more things are remaining
open because it doesn't seem there's any political
willingness to start shutting things down.
But people are staying home more and more because
they see the numbers and that's the reality.
You can't short change actually dealing with the
problem and focusing only on haphazardly fixing
the symptoms. But it just doesn't work and
it's not work. Then we're seeing it now.
We'll continue discussing this on the
show's Instagram at David Pakman show.
And if you're on Instagram, you might as
well find me on Instagram at David Dot.